Rob Kardashian is under investigation  the LAPD confirmed to ET on Thursday  that Rob is being investigated by the  police department's threat management  unit for allegedly threatening a man /  blac Chyna I'm obviously more than  willing to do whatever it takes for  China authorities told ET the 29 year  old reality star was named as a suspect  in a crime report that occurred  Wednesday night in North Hollywood Rob  allegedly threatened actor and singer  pilot Jones with physical harm over his  fiancee according to TMZ in a new teaser  on Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kim  shared how she's worried about her  brother's relationship drama I know that  Robin China had like an unstable  relationship there's obviously two sides  to every story and you know they just  know how to push each others buttons and  my brother just like shuts down